en el vídeo pasado encontramos los
valores propios de esta matriz a de esta
matriz de 3 por 3 de aquí y lo que
hicimos más o menos para repasar un poco
fue decir a un valor lambda es un valor
propio si y sólo si satisface esta
ecuación de aquí para algún vector b
distinto del vector 0 es decir si sólo
si a por el vector b es igual a lambda
por el vector de y esto pasaba usando un
poco de álgebra de vectores sí solo si
esta ecuación de aquí se satisfacía sí
solo si lambda por la matriz identidad
menos a que todo eso era una matriz de
hecho vimos que era esta matriz de aquí
abajo todo eso multiplicado por algún
vector b distinto es 0 era igual al
vector 0 así que con eso concluimos que
para que existiera un valor propio y un
vector propio era necesario que el
determinante de esta matriz fuera 0 eso
nos llevó al polinomio característico de
la matriz a que es precisamente el
determinante de esta matriz
raíces de ese polinomio de ese polinomio
eran precisamente los valores propios de
la matriz a así que concluimos que los
valores propios de a tenían que ser
lambda igual a 3
lambda igual a menos 3 ahora viene la
parte interesante porque ahora tenemos
que encontrar los espacios propios que
corresponden a estos valores ahora voy a
encontrar los vectores propios de la
matriz a ok
hagamos primero el caso hagamos primero
el caso en el que el valor propio estrés
así que vamos a hacer primero y el caso
lambda igual a 3 vamos a encontrar todos
los valores propios correspondientes
perdón todos los vectores propios
correspondientes al valor propio 3 y
bueno yo sé que estos vectores propios
son precisamente los que resuelven esta
ecuación para lambda igual a 3 así que
lo primero que tengo que hacer es
encontrar los vectores tales que la
matriz 3 x la identidad menos a por el
vector b sea igual al vector 0 3 por la
identidad menos a pues simplemente
sustituyó aquí por lambda igual a 3 y
obtengo
4 que sería la más 131 es 4 - 2 - 2 todo
lo que está fuera la diagonal se queda
igual
- 23 menos 2 es 1
uno acá también menos 2 1
32 es uno de nuevo entonces estoy
buscando todos los vectores b
tales que su producto con esta matriz me
da el vector
eso es precisamente el espacio nulo de
esta matriz entonces lo que puedo hacer
es encontrar el espacio nulo de su forma
escalonada reducida porque es
exactamente el mismo entonces vamos a
llevar esta matriz a su forma escalonada
reducida
voy a dejar el primer renglón como esta
4 - 2 - 2
y voy a cambiar el segundo renglón por
dos veces al segundo más el primero
entonces dos por menos dos es menos 44
es 0 2 por unas 2 - 2 es 0 2 por 12 más
menos 2 es cero y voy a hacer lo mismo
el tercer renglón lo voy a cambiar por
dos veces el tercero más el primero y
eso me da cero de nuevo 0 0
bien entonces estoy buscando los
vectores los vectores bay que voy a
escribir como b1 b2 b3
tales que multiplicados por esta matriz
me den el vector 0 0
ok esto no está en forma escalonada
reducida perfectamente pero con esto ya
puedo trabajar esta matriz por este
vector su primera entrada sería 4 x de 1
- 2 x de 2 - 2 por b 3 es igual a 0
y entonces de aquí puedo dividir todo
esto entre cuatro y escribirlo como b1
menos un medio de b2
- un medio de uve 3 es igual a 0
o lo que es lo mismo lo que es lo mismo
de uno es igual a un medio de v2 más un
medio de de 3 ok si ahora digo si b 2 es
igual algún número algún número a ib3 es
igual algún número de entonces entonces
el espacio propio el espacio propio
correspondiente al anbaa igual a 3 el
espacio de vectores el conjunto de
vectores que tienen por valor propio a 3
es igual al conjunto de vectores b1 b2
b3
que tienen la forma
vamos a describirlo así por algún vector
más de por algún sector
en el primer vector la segunda entrada
es a así que puedo ponerlo como 1 por y
dejar la tercera entrada que es b que no
tiene nada que ver con nada como 0 para
este ahora la b 2 no tiene nada que ver
con nada así que lo pongo como 0 y
escribo 1 acá uno por vez b que es de 3
y veo no es un medio debe 2 más un medio
debe 3 así que es un medio de a más un
medio de b
donde a y b son números reales
bien así que este es el espacio propio
correspondiente al valor 3 si multiplico
cualquier vector de este conjunto por la
matriz
el resultado es tres veces el vector
original y esto también lo puede
escribir de la siguiente forma puede
decir que el espacio propio
correspondiente al valor propio 3 es
sencillamente el sub espacio vectorial
generado por los vectores estos dos un
medio 10
un medio 0 1
todas las combinaciones lineales de
estos dos vectores forman parte del
espacio propio correspondiente al valor
propio 3 ahora tengo que calcular los
vectores propios con valor propio menos
3 sale pues aquí ya no tengo espacio a
trabajar ya no tengo espacio libre así
que me voy a llevar esto para abajo
pego
o aquí y aquí vamos a trabajar así que
bien ahora vamos a hacer el caso el caso
en el que el valor propio es menos 3 y
entonces la matriz que tenemos que
considerar para resolver esta ecuación
es esta matriz pero con landa igual a
menos 3 o sea sustituir en esta matriz
lambda igual a menos 3 si hago esta
sustitución obtengo
- tres más uno es menos 2
todo lo que está fuera de la diagonal sé
que al menos 2 - 2 en los dos menos 211
este valor es menos 3 - 2 es menos cinco
y menos tres menos dos es menos 5
perfecto ok entonces quiero encontrar
quiero encontrar los vectores de tales
que el producto de esta matriz por el
vector b sea igual al vector 0 eso es
precisamente la ecuación que tengo que
resolver esta de aquí para encontrar los
vectores propios entonces esto es lo
mismo que encontrar de nuevo el espacio
nulo de esta matriz así que igual a como
lo hicimos en el caso anterior vamos a
escalonar esta matriz vamos a llevarla a
su forma escalonada reducida
y entonces
como el primer renglón son puro 12 es lo
que voy a hacer es primero que nada
dividir todo el primer renglón por menos
2 entonces obtengo 1
voy a cambiar el segundo renglón por el
segundo renglón menos el primer renglón
entonces obtengo menos dos menos 20
5 - 2 es menos 31 - menos dos son los
más dos que es 3 ahora el tercer renglón
lo voy a cambiar por el tercer renglón
menos el primer renglón entonces menos 2
menos -2 es menos dos más dos que es 01
- menos dos es uno más dos que es tres y
menos cinco menos -2 es menos 3
perfecto
ok ahora lo que voy a hacer
vamos a dejar el primer renglón tal y
como está vamos a dejar esto como 111 y
ahora voy a cambiar el segundo renglón
por el segundo renglón entre menos 30
entre menos 30 menos 3 entre menos 31 y
13 entre menos 3 es menos 1 ahora voy a
sumarle al tercer renglón le voy a sumar
el segundo renglón 00 es 0 3 más menos
30 y menos 33 es cero o que ya casi
acabamos
ahora lo único que voy a hacer lo único
que voy a hacer es sumarle el segundo
renglón
más bien lo único que voy a hacer es
restarle el segundo renglón al primero
10 es 11 10 y 1 - menos uno es 2 el
segundo renglón se queda igual
0 1 - 1 y entonces el renglón también
así que esa es mi matriz en forma
escalonada reducida y lo que quiero
hacer es encontrar los ves los sectores
ve que puede escribir como los vectores
de 1 de 2 de tres tales que esta matriz
por este vector me dé el vector cero es
decir
0 0 0
ok si yo hago este producto de matriz
por vector la primera entrada sería 1
por b 10 por b dos más dos por tres y
eso tiene que ser igual a cero así que
de uno de uno más dos veces de tres es
igual a cero y la segunda entrada sería
cero por de uno más uno por b2 b3 es
igual a cero es decir de dos menos de
tres es igual a cero si ahora yo digo
si ve 3 es igual algún parámetro t
entonces
entonces qué me dicen estas ecuaciones
pues ve uno
b1 b2 b3 es igual a cero así que si
restó dos veces ve tres de ambos lados
tengo que ver uno es igual a menos dos
veces de tres por lo que es lo mismo de
uno es igual a menos dos te recuerden
que b 3 es igual a t esta ecuación si le
sube 3 de ambos lados se convierte en b
2 es igual a b3 así que de 2 es igual a
t
bien y esto que nos dice pues nos dice
que estos vectores estos vectores b1 b2
b3 los puedo escribir como
- 2 t
para algún número real t
bien vamos a escribir esto formalmente y
la forma de hacerlo es decir que el
espacio propio correspondiente al valor
propio menos 3 es el conjunto de
vectores es el conjunto de vectores b1
b2 b3
que tienen que formar pues si de aquí
factor hizo la te puede escribir esto
como todos los vectores que son de la
forma de veces el vector menos 2
donde te
es un número real o dicho de otro modo
el espacio propio correspondiente al
valor propio nanda igual a menos 3 es
igual al sub espacio vectorial generado
por el vector menos 211 porque este sub
espacio serían simplemente todos los
múltiplos escalares de este vector que
es este conjunto otra cosa interesante y
para lo cual voy a copiar este sub
espacio voy a copiar este espacio propio
el espacio propio correspondiente al
valor propio 3 voy a traer acá abajo
es que estos dos espacios son
ortogonales si se fijan
este vector es portugal a estos dos
vectores si toman su producto interior
con cualquiera de estos dos vectores les
dará 0 bien ahora vamos a hacer una
gráfica vamos a hacer una gráfica para
ver qué significa hoy como se ve todo
esto que nos está haciendo recapitulando
brevemente nuestra transformación de que
valía multiplicar por la matriz a que
tenía por valores propios a menos 3 y a
3 y estos eran sus espacios propios
correspondientes el espacio propio
correspondiente al valor propio 3 es un
plano en r3 porque está generado por
estos dos vectores digamos que esos dos
vectores se ven algo así
esos dos vectores de allí y esto es el
espacio propio correspondiente al valor
propio 3 por otra parte el espacio
propio correspondiente al valor propio
menos 3 es una recta porque está
generado por un solo vector que es
ortogonal al plano 3
esto sería
-3 y este sería el vector que lo genera
entonces si yo tengo un vector x en este
plano en este espacio propio de tres
digamos el vector x la transformación lo
que hace es lo multiplica por tres es un
vector que tiene la misma dirección y el
mismo sentido pero tres veces la
longitud 100 si ahora éste fuera el
vector x entonces la transformación lo
mandaría a digamos ese vector bien
entonces si ahora me tomo un vector x
que está en el espacio propio
correspondiente a menos 3 m3
entonces la transformación lo que le
haría sería cambiarle el sentido ahora
iría hacia abajo y multiplicarlo por 3
así que tendría tres veces la longitud y
en sentido contrario esto sería a por
equis y con esto ya encontramos todos
los vectores propios agrupados en dos
espacios propios correspondientes a dos
valores propios son una infinidad de
vectores propios en estos dos sub
espacios y esto ya es un gran logro
porque ahora lo hicimos con una matriz
de 3